hemos visto las fracciones como una
ayuda para representar partes de un todo
o enteros sin embargo en este vídeo lo
que me gustaría es que bueno lleguemos a
expandir la idea de estas fracciones
dentro de una recta numérica ustedes ya
conocen esto y vamos a colocar lo que
pensemos que tengo una recta numérica
esta es mi recta numérica que va del 0
al 2 por aquí estará el 1
y qué pasa si yo busco representar la
fracción
voy a representar la fracción
tres cuartos
este 4 casi no se ve voy a cambiar el
color
tres cuartos
cómo es que voy a representar esta
fracción dentro de una recta numérica sí
ya sé cómo representar números enteros
pero y las fracciones esto está muy
sencillo dado que esta fracción tiene un
numerador menor que el denominador
sabemos que está antes del primer entero
es decir será un número menor a 1 así es
que vamos a nuestro denominador y nos
indica que está dividido en cuatro
partes iguales
vamos a colocar cuatro partes iguales
esta sería la mitad
y esta sería la forma en que partimos en
cuatro partes iguales tenemos una dos
tres cuatro considerando que estas
cuatro partes son iguales
el numerador nos representará cuántas
veces nos hemos movido hacia el 1 en
este caso porque es positivo tengo tres
cuartos indica que tenemos 123 en esta
posición se encontrará tres cuartos si
yo quisiera saber qué números se
encuentran en estas en estas mismas
particiones tendré que de cualquier
manera son cuartos porque está dividido
en cuartos y aquí me habría movido una
dos por lo que me
numerador
0 2
y mi denominador me indicará que está
dividido en cuatro partes iguales dos
cuartos
finalmente en anaranjado
pondré cuál es la representación de este
punto tenemos cuatro partes iguales
divididas y sólo me movido una hacia el
entero tendrá entonces un cuarto
voy a mover esta fracción
hacia acá
entonces esto haría que el 0 serían 0
cuartos
también lo podemos representar así sin
embargo no es tan común podemos dejarlo
vacío
este es el que me interesa también mucho
tenemos 1 2 3 4 partes iguales y si nos
hemos movido una dos tres cuatro
tendremos aquí cuatro cuartos que tiene
todo el sentido saben porque cuatro
cuartos significa que tengo cuatro
piezas
de cuatro piezas posibles
lo que eso me representa un entero
vamos bien
si nosotros tenemos cualquier número
distinto a 0 dividido entre ese mismo
número
tendremos igual a 1
recuerda que esta línea nos representa
literalmente una división 4 entre 4 es
igual a 1
y de ahí sale que es un entero ahora que
tenemos este concepto y esta
visualización de como representamos las
fracciones en una recta numérica vamos a
hacer ejercicios que tal que nos dice
mueve el punto anaranjado a 5 sextos en
la recta numérica
aquí tenemos ya la recta numérica que va
del 0 al 1 y está dividido en 1 2 3 4 5
6 es correcto porque el denominador es 6
así es que dice que nos hemos movido a
cinco de esas seis piezas moveremos 1 2
3 4 5 tal vez si no tuviéramos la recta
numérica dividida sería un poco más
complicado sin embargo ahora sabemos que
tomamos el denominador y eso indica en
cuántas partes iguales se ha dividido
del 0 al 1 vamos a comprobar la
respuesta y es correcta vamos a hacer un
par más que estas son muy divertidas
bueno a mí me gustan mucho
mueve el punto anaranjado a cuatro
quintos o cuatro sobre cinco en la recta
numérica este cinco que nos representan
pues que está dividido en uno dos tres
cuatro cinco espacios iguales y de esos
nos moveremos al cuarto
uno dos tres cuatro cuatro quintos
cuatro de los cinco espacios
es correcto una más mueve el punto
anaranjado a dos quintos en la recta
numérica ustedes ya saben que esto está
dividido en 1 2 3 4 5 como lo indica el
denominador y el numerador nos dice que
nos movamos hacia el segundo bloque
de estos 5 que tenemos como un entero
dos quintos comprobemos la respuesta y
es correcta